the Netherlands and Denmark have pledged
U.S made fighter jets to Ukraine for its
ongoing war with Russia the
announcements made during President
Vladimir zielinski's visit to the NATO
member countries the F-16 fighter jets
will be delivered once conditions for
the transfer have been met
the purpose of this donation is to
defend Ukraine and and the country
um and on the concrete questions when
are we planning to deliver
well the screening is going on now the
training will soon be starting and
hopefully around New Year the first
group of planes will be leaving Denmark
going to to Ukraine around six and then
hopefully next year eight more planes
are leaving Denmark for Ukraine
Alexander vo Travers is the
editor-in-chief of the Swiss military
review explains how the supply of F-16
fighter jets will impact Ukraine's war
efforts
he can imagine that the situation is
going to change in the coming weeks and
coming months uh because uh Russian Air
Forces have become emboldened uh by the
fact that uh less and less uh Ukrainian
aircraft were able to take to the air
and intercept and fire missiles at them
um so without a sufficient number of
airplanes the Ukrainian Air Force cannot
maintain its uh its uh territorial its
uh airspace Integrity we're going to see
in the coming months more Ukrainian
airplanes and therefore this will
probably push back the Russian Air Force
strikes these airplanes are multi-role
and because they are fitted with a very
Comprehensive electronic suite and even
the older generation f-16s that we are
talking about now now have been
modernized repeatedly they are capable
of air defense they are capable of
reconnaissance including electronic
suppression jamming missions and of
course striking capabilities so air to
ground capabilities as well